Joanna, there is a study that shows one in 60 dads end
up raising a child that doesn't belong to him. So non-paternity is obviously
an issue at fairly high prevalence in United States in general and
possibly the world in general. How
does 23andMe deal with issues of non-paternity?
>> Well, I've heard estimates similar to that
a big range of estimates. from 2% to
10% of, of kids. are
not aware of who their biological father is. So this is certainly a big issue
for 23andMe. because it's one of the most high impact
results that someone who signs up for 23andMe can get.
>> Mm hm.
>> And before people sign up it's very important
that they consider the possibility of making a discovery about
biological relationships in their family that they
didn't previously know about. And so, and that's
why when we launched the service, from the
very beginning, we, in our Terms of Service,
we said. be, you should be aware that
you may learn things about yourself that, that
you find uncomfortable, that are disturbing, including that
your biological father is not your biological father
that the person you know to be your father is not
your biological father. So we were very explicit from the very beginning
that this is a possibility. And so that, the people are
aware that that is something that can come out of DNA analyses.
>> And so are people, do you find
many people not aware that the personal genetic
services offered at 23, I mean, is essentially,
in a way can be like a paternity test?
>> Well,
many, Organizations that do official paternity testing are
doing it in a way that it the
evidence will hold up in a court. So it's a bit it's a bit of a different
process. So for 23andMe customers it's more like
something they just discover right when they're exploring
their data. And the main way that people
discover non-paternity is if they find that their genetic
relationship to another family member is not
what they had anticipated. That, that they are,
instead of being a full sibling with someone
they think that's their sibling, they're a half
sibling, because they have different fathers. So
that's not an, unusual, and. one resource that
we provide is we provide a forum, a
discussion forum where many of our customers put
out their questions to other members of the
23andMe community. And that's where we've seen evidence
of people discovering an opportunity. And very often
they have questions like, how do I check with,
out, to find out whether this is true or not. How do I handle conversations with
other members of my family? And, other members
of the 23andMe community often come forward with advice
on, you know, who else should be tested in the family how to, you know, approach
other family members and I've seen people reporting
cases where they've said, I'm not going to tell my dad that
I've discovered this, because he's been my dad all my life. And
and there's no need for us to change that.
>> Sure, I, I imagine.
>> And so people make these big
personal decisions, once they get this this information.
>> Now is there any way for 23andMe to actually track
this discovery rate, or is it just a sort of organic thing?
>> So we do not do any formal
tracking, it's really if someone comes forward with
a story, And said, and tells us and
said and tells us that they made this discovery.
That's the only way we actually find it out. So it does happen, we have
seen people coming forward with stories about
discovering that their father's not their genetic father.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But it's sort of the two sides of
the coin. We've, we've also had cases where people
have discovered their father's not their genetic father. But
then they've actually gone on to discover their biological father,
>> So it becomes sort of a story of discovery.
>> That's right.
>> And not
just a loss.
>> they've actually found their biological
relatives through DNA as well. And, so,
it's all part of the big picture that you know DNA is all
about families and you can discover that relationships aren't as you think they
are and you can find new relationships that you didn't weren't aware of before.